In 1951 doctors took a tissue sample
from a poor dying black woman that was
given to researches without setting
knowledge or have permission.
The healer cells names for the patient's
first and last name acted differently
than other cells in the lab.
They were heartier and they replicated
at an amazing rate. They also didn't die.
Cultivation of healer launched a
revolution in biomedical research and is a
multibillion dollar industry.
The cells were sold all over the world
and lead to important advances to find
human kinds, deadliest diseases
including polio, HIV, and cancer.
No one aside from the patients, doctors
and lead researchers knew the origins.
If the healer cells, I'll say her
name or anything else about her life.
Two decades passed before this mystery
woman was revealed and it was many more
years before her family had answers
to their most burning questions.
Today we examined the woman behind
the notorious and immortal Hilo cells.
Henrietta lacks
on August the first 1920 and Louisa lags
pleasant, gave birth to a baby girl,
the Reta in a shack at the end of a
dead end road in Roanoke, Virginia.
At some point during her life.
Laresa changed her name to Henry Assa
though no one knows why they're shy
overlooking the train depot was the young
girl's home until I mother tragically
died. Henrietta at this point
was any four years olds.
Eliza passed from this life to the next
to cheering Charles bath with her 10th
baby, leaving our
husbands, Johnny or widow,
unable to take care of all the children.
He sent them away to live with family
125 miles southeast from Roanoke and
southern Virginia. The lacks
family lived in the town of clover,
just past difficult creek on
the banks of the river of death.
Now this might sound like a bad omen,
but it's in the 1920s it looks like a
lot of small towns in rural Virginia on
the outskirts, fields of tobacco
and old plantation houses,
dotted the rolling hills and on
main streets down the dusty roads.
The town buzzed with life. There
was a movie theater, grocery store,
post office shops, restaurants,
and a train depot. Henrietta.
We didn't recognize the town today cause
I've lost so many of us residents by
the late 1990s that it's official charter
was revoked in the last census in 2010
the population had dwindled to a mere 438
when Johnny came to town in 1924 Henry
Essa and ten nine brothers and sisters
had to be divided up amongst the
relatives.
No one could take all 10 children.
Henrietta ended up living
with her grandfather.
Tommy lacks in a four room log
cabin calls the home house.
Generations of Laksas have lived and died.
They're buried in the small family plus
Henrietta could see out of a window
formerly slave quarters.
The home house was a simple structure
with no electricity or indoor plumbing,
only gaslands and water that Henry has
a holds up from the creek below. Tommy,
it was already caring for another
grandchild. Nine year old day.
When Henry came to live at the home house,
the children shared a room.
Men's works everyday together planting
and harvesting the tobacco and tending to
the animals in the garden.
After the day's work,
they sometimes swam in the swimming hole,
had bonfires at night and played ring
around the Rosie with their cousins once a
month during harvest,
grandpa,
me and the cousins headed to South Boston
to the second largest tobacco market
in the nation to sell their crop.
It was a time they all look forward to,
even if the market wasn't a safe place
for children, whether it's free flowing,
booze, prostitution, and
it's the occasional murder
at the home house. Henrietta,
I work every morning at four o'clock
to milk the cows and feed the pigs.
When she was finished
with her morning chores,
she walked two miles to the schoolhouse
for colored children pass the white
school where children three rocks
is her and called her names.
Jim Crow laws segregated blacks from
whites and that remained in place until
1964 in the short 31 years of her life,
it was all she knew.
By sixth grade, Henry has a walk
to the school house one last time,
like day and the other Lexus she dropped
out to work in the tobacco fields.
Few public photos of
Henrietta lacks exist.
The most well known is a striking
image from a 19 seventy's rolling stone
article of a smiling at smartly
dressed woman in a skirt, suits,
jackets and open toe sandals.
I hadn't sought firmly placed on her
hips into a Walmart highs glimmer at the
camera. She looks self assured with a
hint of mischief spread about in her grin.
It's obvious even by today's standards
that Henrietta was beautiful.
She was the envy of other
women and desirable to all
of the men are rounds out.
It wasn't only her beauty that attracted
people to Henrietta have cousin QT
described errors.
Lovie dovie as kind as she was pretty
always taking care of family and friends
in need as a child.
Cuti had been stricken with
polio and Henrietta took
care of him when it got bad.
Everyone who knew her remembers Henrietta
and her as a Gen Xer, caregiver,
and a strong woman. Even when cancer
was spreading inside her body,
she didn't make a fuss or
draw attention to herself.
Very few people knew until the
end quite how she suffered.
Henry had no shortage of men vying
for her affection. As a young woman,
Henry asset chose day,
a cousin with whom she shared a bedroom
and had spent countless hours with since
the age of four they had their first baby,
a boy named Lawrence out of wedlock.
When Henry out,
it was barely 14 years old.
He was born on the home house floor
like his father runs numerous cousins,
aunts and uncles and grandparents
before and other likes.
Baby Elsie was born four years later.
Eventually Henry Essa and day said their
vows and a private marriage ceremony.
On April the 10th 1941
she was 21 and he was 25
by the winter of 1941 the country was
at war and small tobacco farms including
Henry Asher and days, well barely
making enough to make ends meet,
but to the north there was
opportunity in the booming factories.
Demand for steel was increasing.
A great migration of black
families came to Turner station.
Mary Lynn's leaving
behind the southern farms.
That's Bethlehem Steel Sperry
points in Baltimore County.
A black man could make up to
80 cents an hour. At the most,
any of the waxes and seen in factories.
Black men took the jobs,
white men rejected and they were exposed
to a host of toxic chemicals including
a speced us. When the man finished
their shifts and return time,
the toxins were shared with their wives
and children through their clothes.
At the urging of Lexus cousin who was
doing well for himself as point Dan
Henrietta moved with their babies to
turn a station starting a new life.
Other cousins made the transition to
including Henry edge as close friends.
Saidi the city was a change for the axes,
but they adjusted and they had fun.
After cleaning, cooking and taking care
of the Children Henry at are in CD,
you would put on their dancing shoes
and sneak out until the wee hours.
The two women boogied laughed and had a
great time and when they weren't dancing,
Henrietta CD and CD's, sister Margaret
Played Bingo in Henry at his living room.
Turn the station was new and exciting,
but Henry Assa preferred the
country whenever she could.
She rode the train back to clover to
work in the fields or Chan barter on the
home house porch. It was here. Uh,
eldest daughter Elsie was most at ease.
Elsie has inherited her mother's
good looks, but she was born special,
are unable to speak or talk.
She made shops and core sounds like the
birds and sometimes flailed her arms in
front of her face.
Years later it was understood that
Elsie had epilepsy and cognitive
developmental delays that left
her unable to communicate.
No one knew what was going on in a
pretty hat that's home in Turner station.
Lc was known to occasionally run
out into the streets screaming.
By the time Henry [inaudible],
who was pregnant with her fifth baby,
Elsie had grown stronger and this made
it near impossible for her mother to take
care of fat to make life easier.
Doctors recommended Henrietta commit
LC to the Crownsville state hospital,
formerly the hospital for the Negro
insane, believing the doctors knew best.
Henry as an institutionalized,
how daughter years later,
a family member said apart
of Henry as a dye of the day,
she left LC at Crownsville.
Henry asset routinely visited her daughter
once a week at the hospital before
she became ill.
After Henry as a died,
no one ever went to
Crownsville to CLC again.
Henry. I said with certain there
was something wrong with her.
A year and a half before a
official cervical cancer diagnosis,
she shared her worry with her cousins
CD and Margaret saying there was a knot
inside and explaining how it hurts
something awful when that man wants to get
with me.
Sweet Jesus aren't them,
but some pains who were then poked to her
stomach over and over and felt nothing.
Maybe it was a baby growing inside.
They suggest it to be sure that
nothing was seriously wrong.
How cousins tried to convince Henrietta
to see a doctor, but she didn't.
And about a week later, Henry out,
so found out she was pregnant.
The ladies reassured her that it was
just the maybe making it feel funny,
but Henrietta wasn't convinced.
Nevertheless,
she didn't us out with Sadie and
Margaret's again and it's the women never
mentioned the conversation
with anyone else.
Henry as a carries her fifth baby
determined after Joe was born,
she wasn't feeling any better.
One a alone in the bathroom.
She slipped into the bathtub
and reached inside herself.
She could feel the not until
day she needed to go and
see a doctor on a referral
from the local physician,
Henry,
as he went to Johns Hopkins Hospital
to see cancers. At this point,
a Henry as a fault.
The doctors would simply fix her right
up on January the 29th 1951 day drove
Henrietta with the three small children
20 miles from town of station to Johns
Hopkins.
Johns Hopkins was not any the hospital.
It was a renowned medical research center.
It also had a public water serving
patients who were too poor to afford
treatments,
many of whom were black in the 1950s and
to discriminatory segregation laws in
the United States. Black patients
could be turned away at hospitals,
doctors' offices and clinics
that soft white patients.
Sometimes the consequences are dire,
including death.
Johns Hopkins was Henry at his best
and only real option for diagnosis and
treatment of cervical cancer while day
sat in the car with their small children
waiting for Henry. After to
return, she met Dr. Howard Jones,
the gynecologist on duty in the exam room.
He reviewed her medical history
and listened to Henrietta.
Describe the lump that she felt
insider when Jones examined her,
he found a hard mass about
the size of a nickel.
The tumor was the color of
grape jello exactly in the spot.
Henrietta said it would be decades later
in his nineties Joan's recalled never
seeing anything like Henry his tumor
during his years practicing medicine,
not before and not since.
During the exam,
Dr. Jones caught a tiny sample of the
tumor to test and it's confirmed what he
suspected was cancerous.
Then he sent Henry as a backhoe into
town to station to await the results.
Jones thought it was odd
that Henry has a heard,
had a full term baby just a few months
prior with no notes mentioning the tumor
or any abnormalities of the
cervix listed in her chart.
It was unlikely physicians
would have missed seeing it,
which meant it must've grown at an
alarming rate. A few days later,
Henrietta received the results back
from the lab epidermoid carcinoma of the
cervix.
Stage one
in 1951 it was standard practice. You
conduct research on public ward hospital.
Patients without consent,
explicit permission or informed consent
from patients wasn't a term that was
coined and so no legal or ethical
standard existed in the United States for
obtaining it.
That's Hopkins,
the den leading cervical cancer experts
in the worlds and it's Dr. Jones,
his boss Richard to Lynn's believed that
since the patients were treated free of
charge, the research was a form of
payment for the hospital services.
When Henrietta when's in for an exam,
a sample from Henry out,
his Chuma was sent to George Gaze lab that
of tissue culture research at Hopkins.
Without our knowledge for years,
gay had been trying unsuccessfully to
grow and keep alive human cells outside of
the body in petri dishes.
Culturing cells allowed scientists to
test their response to all kinds of drugs,
diseases,
and conditions in order to do understand
how the human body would react.
The benefit of this was that it
didn't cause any harm to the patients.
When Henry Su went to Hopkins
and agreement was already
in place to provide gaze
research lab with patients,
cancerous tumor samples primarily to
be used in studies to prove to Lynn's
theories to lens was a believer that
of the two types of cervical cancer,
the noninvasive variety carcinoma in
situ could spreads and has become deadly.
This was contrary to what the majority
of researchers thought at the time,
and physicians practices
followed this conclusion,
treating only the invasive
cancers aggressively.
He actually had another motive
for his research using cells to,
so Lindsey wanted to reduce the number
of unjustifiable hysterectomy by
detecting what wasn't
cervical cancer at all.
The Pap smear test you use to identify
changes to a woman's cervical cells was
developed only a decade earlier,
but few physicians could interpret the
results and treat patients accordingly in
extreme cases.
So women who just needed a few
antibiotics declare up a minor infection.
Might've had a entire uterus
removed in a surgical procedure.
When Gaze lab assistant Mary
received Henrietta's tissue sample.
She had every reason to believe the cells
if they lived at all would die within
a few days. She was eating
lunch and decided to finish
a sandwich first. So far,
even with gay standards,
meticulous process and emphasis
on sterilization is lap.
Had little success with
growing human cells.
When Mary got to work on
Henry at has cancer cells,
she carefully and precisely sliced
the samples with steady hands,
makes the media the cells would need
to grow and labeled them healer for the
first two letters of Henrietta's first
and last names. Then she left them alone,
not really expecting very much. By
the next morning to marry, surprise,
Henrietta cells had divided and
in the days ahead he looked,
kept making copies of themselves.
They grew unlike any cells before and
expanded into as much space as Mary would
give them.
Gay was ecstatic because the cells were
growing like crabgrass and soon among
researchers. Word was out
about the amazing healer cells.
Everyone knew the implications
for furthering biomedical
research and this was
gays goal. See, when he
began sending he the cells,
do any scientist interested in
using them for that own studies?
Henry has his treatment for
cervical cancer was radium
or radioactive metal that
glows blue in this highly toxic
in the early 20th century.
Upon radiums discovery, it was hailed as
a miracle to cure all kinds of elements.
Now,
Radian does kill cancer cells,
but it can burn skin from a person's
body if it's given in high enough
quantities being radioactive radium.
It also causes cancer.
In 1951 the radium treatment for cervical
cancer involved placing tubes inside
the patient's next to the affected area.
Common side effects include nausea,
vomiting, weakness, and anemia. If
Henry has experienced any of these,
she didn't let on or seem sick. A tall
after treatment started. Henrietta,
finally the same cousins. She confided
in about the knots inside out.
She didn't want anyone to worry,
but the frequent visits to Johns Hopkins
would mean she would be away and it's
people would certainly wonder.
Initially the radium treatments
seemed to work and doctors recorded.
The tumor is having vanished.
As therapy progressed, Henry,
it didn't feel any
better and to her horror,
her abdomen turned from
soft brown to black as coal.
One day she lifted up her shirt and showed
CD and Margaret's and said it felt as
though the blackness be
spreading more than inside.
The radium treatments didn't
cure Henrietta's cancer.
By the fall of 1951 her body was
full of tms and a diaphragm, bladder,
cervix, kidneys, lungs, and it was
all causing her excruciating pain.
She Land Better Johns Hopkins and
screamed out like it was the devil of pain
itself between the
treatments and the cancer.
Henrietta was weak and our kidneys when
no longer flushing out dangerous toxins
in their blood.
She had to receive numerous transfusions.
The doctors tried different
medications to ease their suffering,
including morphine, which didn't even
touch the pain on one desperate attempt.
The doctors even injected alcohol into
our spine, but nothing seemed to work.
All anyone could do was sit beside her
bed and pray. Henry has to to Gladys,
was it a bad side? The night she succumbed
to cancer, knowing her time had come,
Henrietta made her sister promised to
take care of our kids and whispered
through tears.
Don't you let anything bad happen to them
children when I'm gone at 12:15 AM on
October the fourth 1951 Henrietta lacks
took her last breath and died in a
hospital bed.
Nobody was sent back to clover and
it's buried in the family plots in an
unmarked grave next to a mother.
The importance of Henrietta cells cannot
be overstated through this immortalized
continuously cultured Cell Line Cancer
Research has advanced vaccines have been
developed.
Gene,
nothing has taken place and treatments
of various diseases have been studied and
other taken.
He [inaudible] have even been put into
space on missions with both Americans and
Russians were tested against an atomic
bomb and where the first human cells to
be cloned,
perhaps the most well known advances
using Hela cells occurred shortly after
Henry at his death in the
midst of a polio epidemic.
The virus was sweeping the country and
it's parents feared for the lives of
their children.
In late summer dubbed polio season,
public swimming pools were
shut down and officials warms.
The virus could be spread by sitting
too close to others. At movie theaters.
By 1950 to 60,000 children were in
fact there's thousands or paralyzed.
A vaccine was in developments by Jonas
Salk that he needed a way to test it in a
lab on a grand scale before injecting
children heal provided the perfect
opportunity.
Soon the healer project at Tuskegee
university began growing the cell line
employing mostly black women,
lab technicians, Tuskegee's,
mass production of healer would serve
as the first of its kind and just help
launched a multibillion dollar industry.
When the first commercial
culture operation began
using Tuskegee's model in an
old fritos factory in Bethesda,
Maryland.
While this groundbreaking biomedical
research was taking place,
only a handful of people could trace
the healers cell line origins back to a
poor 31 year old black women with cervical
cancer two decades would pass before
the name Henrietta lacks was
finally released to the public.
Yeah.
For many years,
members of the lacks family never knew
how Henry has his cells were used to
advance medical research. Indeed, when
her name was released to the public,
many questions where it's still
left unanswered. The children,
especially her daughter Deborah,
were too young to remember.
Her mother runs long to know what she
was like, what her favorite color was,
and whether or not she
breastfed her not knowing,
not understanding how my mother's cells
could still be living after our death
was terrifying and cost the family great
anxiety and pain and sons and husbands
day.
We're mostly angry with Johns Hopkins.
The doctors and George Gay Day never
gave the hospital permission to use.
His wife sells and it didn't seem right
or fair that people were making millions
of dollars from selling them
by members of the family,
couldn't even afford health insurance.
Hopkins has made public statements that
the hospital has never done regularly
profited from Hilo runs at the time.
No federal regulations were in place for
obtaining permission to use Henrietta
cells for research.
A book published in 2010 by Walter
Rebecca Skloot and to movie starring Oprah
Winfrey has recently brought greater
attention to the women behind the immortal
Hela cells,
raising ethical questions for the well
to ponder for now over 60 years after her
death,
Henrietta [inaudible] cells live on
and just continue to provide us with in
measurable value in the fight
to cure and eradicate disease.
For that we can be grateful.
And now we know a little bit more
about the woman Henrietta lacks.
So I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographics. If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube. If you actually want to
get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that will send
you a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when
we put out a new video. Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.